it's it's really special to be back and
it's just you want to record we really
congratulate everyone for being here
today at this talk not my talk the
seminar because I actually started
actually I had like I came to the
seminar this is actually my favorite
seminar and it's particular goods to
take the seminar early at your Stanford
career because it's one of those
important intersection points between
design technology and engineering and
for me in particular like coming through
this class I'm glad I did in my second
week because it ended up you know
causing me to change my major it was an
image compression and then I started
realizing like what am I going to do
with all this image compression like
it's just technology it has to be
applied somewhere and that's kind of
where this seminar is so pivotal when I
started seeing the speakers here in the
different different connections and
different things that people were able
to do with the work I just realized like
wow you know there's it just opened my
mind actually allowed me to realize that
there's this thing called design there's
this thing called human-computer
interaction and it really like put my
Curie in a very different path so
congratulations everyone for being here
this early and this early in the
semester you don't have to change your
major just enjoy enjoy the show the
second thing is this this talk is going
to be about design and it's going to be
about creativity and I probably got some
of my best lessons about creativity from
Manish when I started working with him
he had two two stories and they will
sound terrible but but they're true
stories the first the first one you know
we were working together on a SIGGRAPH
paper and I was getting ready to to
present that talk and Manish made me
rehearse that talk made me rehearse that
talk I mean like at some point I was
like Minnie we've done this 20 times and
he's like no practice it again and I was
like it's gonna be fine he's like George
you know understand I want you to enjoy
your first SIGGRAPH talk notice he
didn't say I want you to be really good
at your first SIGGRAPH talk he said I
want you to enjoy your first cigarette
talk and that was really smart because
you know who knows if I'm going to be a
good speaker or not
if I enjoy the process I'm gonna get a
better I'll become a better speaker
eventually right so there was a really
really good first lesson the second one
took me more years to figure out what he
really meant which was like Manish comes
to me and says like I really hope you're
gonna fail he didn't quite say it that
way but what what he was trying to say
is like you know George you've been
taking your projects pretty safe you
know everything you've been doing kind
of worked out you know allow yourself to
fail and that was a really really
important lesson too but it took me I
think it actually required me becoming a
CEO of a company understand how much
failure you can do in a day-to-day job
but also realizing that you know what
it's it's okay
like if you turn around and learn from
it you know things will become better so
that's kind of like the two big
takeaways right there you don't even
have to watch the rest of the talk is
that if you want to create become a
great creative thinker or a great
scientist when you're exploring
something new like you don't know
exactly what's going to happen but what
you can control is your approach to the
process and the environment you're in it
all right so being open to failure is is
about accepting that you're about to
move into the frontier you have no idea
what's going to happen you might stumble
and crash right you might step into some
nirvana
like environment you don't know you're
at the frontier right allow yourself
allow yourself to do that the second
thing is like you know when you're doing
something your very first time you're
always going to suck like just be okay
with that and you'll become better so
there's some really really good lessons
and turns out that's what we've been
doing at 53 we've been really going in
and and building are we gonna dial up
our the modem sounds gonna happen any
moment okay this will be an interesting
one what you know what we're doing at 53
is really taking different technologies
and applying it to the creative process
there was a pivotal moment about 10
years into my career at Microsoft I was
working on two projects at that time on
one hand I had was working on the
productivity tool the productivity tools
Word PowerPoint Excel which was all
about how to make people more efficient
and then on the other hand
working on entertainment products Xbox
alright which essentially is how to get
people to just waste their time I'm or
just you know enjoy themselves but it's
it's this really really funny thing it's
like either we're gonna become like you
know it's kind of a fatalist version of
it like we're either gonna become better
cogs in the machine or you're just gonna
play games right well are we really
using technology for what it should be
used for you know and that's kind of
where I realized is that you know we
have to use all the great technology
that we have and put it in service of
human creativity right like you can't
win by being more innovative
you can't win by being more efficient
you have to innovate at some point right
the the challenges of today is not about
you know creating one so you have to
keep creating right and the one
renewable resource or the everlasting
resource art we have is our creativity
so how do we maximize that and then we
can also enjoy ourselves and be more
efficient right but man what if we could
use all of the compute power and
everything we really have to make humans
more creative like what a world could we
live in that's where the idea of 53 then
came about 53 stands for the length of
the average arms reach space between
head heart and blank canvas it's where
people create it's a very special space
everyone has it everyone has that era
where where they can do their best work
technology will come and go right we
want to make sure that the right tools
get invented for that space so that
people can create this all started out
with a product called paper paper is
where ideas begin right we're going to
start at the very beginning of the
creative process and for actually I
should probably ask have people seen the
product paper people know of mental most
people have seen I'll skip but it's it's
a digital notebook it's it's pretty
sweet this is a great iPad application
is also available in iPhone download it
it's great let's talk about what it
really takes to have ideas and this
quote actually ships with every version
of paper to have a great idea have lots
of them right and the second part that
Thomas Edison didn't say there it's like
you also have to capture them some form
the universal language for capturing and
ideas to sketch but a challenge at that
time was that most graphics programs
were really complicated you have to like
adjust opacity you have to fiddle with
line way it's like a lot of stuff route
like man I just want to get my idea out
like why do we have to deal with all
those settings and what had happened is
iPad emerged and people reporting
software from a desktop right for iPad
with all of the legacy in every button
in every setting on to it except that we
had moved into a gestural interface and
a gestural environment where that fine
motor control of acquisition actually
didn't exist it's a gestural interface
so we set the challenge for ourselves to
develop sketching system that had no
settings that just allowed you to focus
on higher-level semantics don't control
opacity use a great sketching tool don't
fiddle with blend modes have a water
color tool right so that was one of the
big insights in paper second thing was
like any ideas start out super fragile
like you know you are usually your
harshest critic right so if you're going
to get an idea out build a beautiful
environment for it and so in paper we've
created a beautiful 3d game like
interface for Peter to place their ideas
and the last one is like yeah like
actually talk to people and think of our
users as noble creatures as creative
beings in that that have a desire to
actually master a skill right so even
while you want to create a simple tool
there needs to be a path for mastery in
it and the way we accomplished that was
actually adding like hired using higher
degrees of freedom to actually provide
more control over particular tools so we
added you know draw tool a sketch tool
outline tool right tool a color tool
that essentially would take care of a
lot of the parameters that you wouldn't
manipulate in a drawing program but put
that into users hands the way we
approach this is oftentimes we're just
studying the real world this is actually
sketched by Andrea Allen one of my
co-founders great at watercolor cook-up
Harrison like my like if I had done this
this would have been like a brown puddle
right but I I knew some computer
graphics from Stanford right so we'd get
together and then essentially just
really try to figure out how do you map
gestural input into the right graphical
outcome so approach pretty much was
let's let's really look at the
parameters like the semantic tasks that
a skilled person is manipulating so here
with watercolor notice that you're
blending colors correctly you're
creating graduations but you're also
able to maintain a hard edge we did a
lot of motion studies of that war
again trying to see like how do you
really layer pigment properly and then
it came mapping touch input into that
type of system to really make sure that
users have the right the you know the
the right control and degrees of freedom
so this process required is actually at
that time since 2011 like to build up
entire prototyping systems in
application to really get the feel right
gazillion takes eventually like we found
in the right setting so this one here
this was quite nice right because you
could go from like hard edges to like
single blurs just by moving speed and
this is a huge step up by the way from
someone having to manipulate a bucket of
water and learn how to manipulate a
brush right now we had a touch interface
that essentially was smart that was
working with your chest or with the
general direction that we were doing to
Bruce a nice optical and visual output
repeated in that process across all of
those tools and tuned them so that they
would work together for for for you know
for like rich effects along that time so
we were doing this work in New York in
Seattle we had like a secret operation
going on working on a hardware product a
digital stylus and for us the thinking
there was that look in a in a direct
manipulation interface meaning a touch
interface we're controlling stuff on the
screen you can do a lot of things but
you can't answer one profound question
which is is the user trying to create
something or are you manipulating
something the way this is today
addressed is typically for some mode
switch or you have to pause and wait and
that really really breaks your flow
right your hand and as humans we were
tool makers we we use tools because they
embody a certain logic and certain
knowledge and allow us to stay in the
flow and I love actually this quote from
Professor fasty one of my teachers here
at Stanford like you know one way of
thinking does not work try another turns
out like your hand has old instincts in
itself in the process of creation and so
a lot of the direct manipulation
interfaces that we have without a stylus
just always felt fundamentally clunky
because they couldn't distinguish
between the creation and the
manipulation activity so then came the
question of like whoa
what should a digital stylist be what
should it look like and you know we
started out looking at all types of
different dimensions the one that ended
up being the most promising the most
exciting for us was actually to look at
expressiveness as that I mentioned
rather than just precision and that made
a lot of sense because when you look at
a gestural input like touch is you want
to stay in the gestural domain so
expression actually makes a lot of sense
so we ended up designing a digital
stylus called pencil where every part of
the object was active you could use the
tip the sides to shade the bacteria race
and we ensured that the entire system
allowed for simultaneous pen and touch
so the crazy thing was that you could
actually take an existing iPad and add
pen and touch capabilities on top of his
simultaneously as an aftermarket
solution it was also a beautiful design
but we didn't quite get there first I'll
actually share the story where we
started this is where we started in a
totally different area we we were
chasing after precision so this was
before it was called pencil we had this
project called pen and man let's talk
about what we did yeah it we essentially
put tracking patterns into a transparent
foil on top of an iPad and then had like
an optical sensor trying to read off
that that pattern you know figured out
how to build all of those from
componentry into the system and then
things got really interesting then we
started doing the optical modeling and
engineering of that piece because to put
like obviously you don't want to put
like a dot pattern onto a display I mean
that's kind of ugly so we had to figure
out how to make the dot pattern
transparent and we eventually figured
this out by going to printing lab in
Japan and then putting the right
droplets onto a file so that the per
Arabic shape of those drops would
reflect light the bright way needless to
say our Bill of Materials are
manufacturing complexity the yield rates
everything we're not looking likely for
us to ship so around that time I saw one
of those folders
it was PowerPoint or like actually was a
keynote presentation pop up another
co-founder was working on a deck called
what was at fifty three back to the
basics you know is it very good at when
you're managing a project and one of
your engineers or designers this
develops a deck called back to the
basics you know you're in trouble or
something great it's going to happen in
this case something great happened
because Jon came up with this sketch and
said is like look you know we're chasing
the wrong goal here where we're going
after precision this should be about
human expression and then just whipped
up the sketch and in this sketch you
actually see the solution for pencil
what he's saying is let's see if we can
just use a capacitive rubber taupe probe
on the top
we'll put a capacitive rubber on the
back and then we'll use a mercury switch
in between to figure out what's up and
down and then I was like okay this seems
pretty interesting except mercury
switches they're poisonous right and
he's like yeah yeah we need to figure
that one out so there are a lot of good
ideas in this design the mercury switch
you had to get rid of and luckily
there's a stuff called bluetooth from
all types of different ways how we're
able to like work this through then you
know we offloaded a lot of essentially
the the hard sensing work to the actual
touch sensor we designed the shape of
pencil to create a very distinct pattern
on the touch sensor of the iPad to then
allow us to distinguish between tip
eraser slides and all of that right so
at the same time that's kind of like one
of those really amazing things that just
you know happen from the engineering
team they also figured out how to make
the system rotationally invariant so you
could rotate your ipad and all types of
different dimensions so if you're
left-handed or right-handed you could
just use your finger and touch to work
on it
all that to say the first time this
stuff works I was such a joy this is
that moment forgive me this will be the
prodigy music from the 90s playing you
want to look at this little blue button
in the top because it'll tell you when
I'll just hit play it'll tell you when
making little black marks there they go
okay all right now it's the beats
dropping start dry dry dry okay
obviously we're really excited about
that but what was remarkable at this we
had now a device right that you know the
iPad we knew if it was the tip the
fingers and the palms what was really
interacting with it and we had put it we
knew we could put it in a really
beautiful shape this had to be
celebrated with wait for it natural
materials you're gonna make a pencil
you're gonna put in everyone's hands
let's make this really warm experience
plastic is neutral metals cold has to be
walnut so that was after John he said
okay you took the project right into the
right direction
we're building a pencil then he came
around we're gonna machine it out of
walnut and I was like John why are we
gonna chord this out how are gonna
manufacture that there's a whole another
it headache but he was right it's made
for a really really beautiful experience
I'm gonna skip the video you can watch
that later on cool thing is so you know
this essentially became pencil became
the archetype for all digital skyline
now right so when you look at a surface
or you look at an Apple pencil
they all have no buttons they allow for
simultaneous pen and touch but it was a
really big deal to figure this out in
the beginning and so there's it if you
go online I'll post this presentation we
have a longer breakdown in that
particular design and then it opened up
a world for us it allowed us to really
move gestural creation forward the next
project that we shipped was called ink
it and it was about diagramming at the
speed of thought the the idea was to you
know there's a story that like you know
back in the old days people would give
artists like a test to draw freehand
circle and you know and we were like
okay we're like dorky engineers we were
like we know how to create an algorithm
to help you draw the circle but we
really wanted to push this forward right
we really wanted to develop a semantic
language where people could gesture an
entire diagram so you see here seeing is
someone drawing
gesturing a circle rectangle square then
being able to draw connectors through
that use your fingers to tap and fill
different areas and then still use the
same diagramming tool to also write so
this is actually a pretty tricky
challenge because at some point like a
small circle is that the letter O or is
that this or is that actually a circle
like these these problems are very real
but for us we now had a system where you
could actually move fluidly from
creation so here's someone who's
creating with pencil and then just
picking up a shape and moving it right
it's like I know this seems so basic but
it was so important to have that
fluidity for us right that someone could
manipulate move and and later on we
would figure out if there's an older
video still so here the same happen with
selection right we're here use the the
stylus actually to select but it turns
out you can actually have your fingertip
just be used for a first selection and
then moving things along
you know the diagram tool got so rich
that it actually could interpret the
first 20 shapes that you'll find in
PowerPoint behind that one of the
innovations here happen next year round
corner detection right this is somewhat
of a specific domain but defining
corners and detecting corners is sort of
at the core of most computer vision
problems up here you see a transition of
someone drawing a square
the sloppy square something becomes more
like a circle and the letter D and and
the blue line indicates what was if
corners were detected or not right and
and notice that you know once you the
shape becomes round or more de like like
the corner detection stops and the way
how we actually figured this out was
actually an insight that came from from
the design and engineering team working
very closely together like they were
literally whiteboarding trying to figure
out the solution to this problem of how
do you distinguish between writing and
and in creating shapes and that's kind
of when Allen when our designers just
looked at it and was like you know how
have you ever noticed that if someone
was whiteboarding quickly like they're
using a completely gestural language
right so we decided to actually then use
speed
a prior to figure out if someone is
trying to place the corner how
deliberate someone is in their creation
process and so down here you can see
like again there's this flag like shape
this this curve here there there could
have been a corner there but you know
the only way for a computer to really
figure out if there was was by us than
mapping speed and velocity into and so
here we actually looked at you know
speed as an inference for placing an
extra corners here that people then can
pick up so here there's some more work
to do in this area right and I still
think like you know we've pushed direct
manipulation touch based interfaces and
gestural interface pretty far right but
the moment you think about them as
creation surface there are a lot of
additional opportunities like you know
what are really the common controls when
you want to autocorrect a stroke like
we're still trying to figure out
autocorrect for text but you know
imagine for freehand creation if you
want to just adjust and text like what
are really the autocorrect mechanisms
for it
what is the programmability story for a
lot of that inference you know are we
gonna use what type of AI what type of
machine learning do you need to
recognize these types of shapes and
really expanders vocabulary then you
know there's some some great functions
and mechanisms that we all know from the
real world right but there is no
standard for it yet like annotations
highlights cut copy searching right I
mean that stuff still needs to be all
invented it took a while for ctrl C to
mean something ctrl V right what in the
free form creation world what would the
equivalent of that be is there like
consistent graphical treatment of ink
ink like the Helvetica of ink what would
that mean like why is that when you go
from one device to the next are we gonna
be like again back to like fiddling with
little settings or is it just gonna look
good out of the out of the box and the
last point is like you know can we make
stylus is more accessible right now the
industry has sort of moved towards the
high end thousand dollar tablets hundred
dollar styli man the world just needs a
bunch of pencils right they should be
cheap they should be everywhere and so
that's still like an open challenge
right that we really want to get that
that out
but let's not lose track of what we're
doing at 53
something really really big was
happening while we're building all this
products it's that people were creating
right they were there they're buying our
products using our products spending
over five thousand years and their
products developing ideas hundreds of
millions of pages and that was on the
one side it was amazing and being part
of all of that creation is everyday
probably one of the most rewarding parts
of the job but it also was a little bit
terrifying it was terrifying for you
know the data ops team and a different
reason they don't want to lose the ideas
but in the grand scheme it's actually a
little bit terrifying because it begs
sort of the question where all these
ideas going right you just can't like
great ideas like you know they want to
be heard they want to affect and
influence others they want to get better
like ideas want to have a life and what
are we gonna do are we just gonna leave
them in paper forever like no they need
to get out they need to move somewhere
and so that started a fairly extensive
hunt of trying to figure out where do
ideas go so our first attempt that this
was a sharing service called mix I'm
gonna play this video because most
people haven't seen this but it started
with a very very idealistic approach to
creativity the idea was like you're
gonna create public domain where you can
just post your ideas into it like take a
piece of paper and send it around the
world and anyone else could just remix
it you could pick on it you could look
sketch on it you can change it up when
we create these remix graphs where
everyone could just essentially work on
each other's ideas and that's what
people did they
you know you have people in China
working people Russia working people in
Germany I mean you get the idea there is
a lot of creation that was happening and
it was all visual and it was all in the
public domain so what did people do they
would create things like a basic
template like Apple announces a watch
someone creates the template and bam
people would start exploring different
user interface ideas around it this is
this is super fun there's so many
different fashion templates that people
created and then you would see different
cultures responding to it in different
looks and different body shapes and
different different identities and then
we had some like you know collaborations
like brands came in like project red to
raise like AIDS awareness and they
created templates that people would
remix and it was it was good in the
sense but it was also very limiting in
others it a highly appeal to people who
were highly fluent with sketches right
so in a way like you know we gave a good
home for people who wanted to
communicate and sketches and so we built
a very active very highly concentrated
community of Skechers but we really
hadn't enabled a broad sense of
creativity the other thing is like you
know having all this works in the public
domain doesn't work for certain types of
creation and particularly if you want to
work on you know commercial projects and
that work so we had in a way built a
system it was very idealistic for a
certain sense set of people but it had
kept a lot of other folks out so we
tried another thing we built paper for
teams we shifted our product around
added a grid display and collaboration
features were then you know design
agencies and different creative teams
and and engineering teams could
essentially like share their ideas in in
a private network that actually
resonated quite well but then we started
getting feature requests you know people
showed up and we're like you know it's
great the sketches are cool
what about a video file could you add a
PDF and we want to add a table we want
to add a chart like all these different
and then we started digging it's like
what are people really doing and it
turns out they were using this
as a really lightweight presentation
tool and I was sort of one of these
really interesting moments like aha wait
what people at the early phase of the
creative process or in the creative
process really need is a great
storytelling tool and and that's kind of
where we said is like we're like in a
really funky place now where on the one
side like you know paper is this great
environment where people are developing
a lot of ideas but the needs to actually
move that into a workflow and move that
into like the the diversity of ideas
that people have like it's it's growing
out of that metaphor that fundamental
metaphor so we made the decision to
actually create a new product a new
presentation product by the way we
strongly think that presentations are
long overdue for a rethink we go all the
way back like you know most presentation
tools that people use today actually
pre-internet right they're pre iPhone
and they're pre messaging right so the
presentation tools that you're using
today actually don't really relate
closely with the communication tools
that you're using we started digging
more into the presentations and found
that over 60% of presentations that
people create or internal facing so a
tool like its take PowerPoint that was
designed as a persuasion tool right
PowerPoint bullet point like I'm gonna
win the argument that's not what people
are using it for they want to use it
much more for collaborative a sense
making tool right but again that wasn't
the design intent of those tools in
those days so we went back and actually
looked at you know where where does this
entire where does the deck actually come
from who invented the deck and this is a
crazy story this is a an ensign to arte
actually has this paper linked on
whatever web pages this is this paper
called I'm not making this up sequential
thematic operate organizations of
publications stop with the with the
subheading of how to achieve coherence
and proposals and reports okay
this came from the the technical writing
community ran into a problem they
started documenting systems
microcontrollers jet engines that were
so complex that the process of creating
documentation just didn't work anymore
the
at that time being let's create an
outline and start filling it in these
systems were so complex that arriving at
an outline was actually intractable so
what would happen is that you know Alex
would go off and start writing I don't
know Alex it was an example Alex would
go off and write about a spark plug
hundreds of pages about that spark plug
when people really just wanted to know
how to fix say you know what happens
when my engine doesn't turn on all right
and at anytime you you you a priori set
up an outline and defy them out the work
have people fill it in like the merge
step that that actually adds up to
something coherent isn't a given right
we have like a modern-day moniker for
this it's the TLDR
right it's it's essentially like I wrote
too much in my document I can't make
sense of it so here's a quick summary
anytime you see a a chat message a long
email chain a document that just goes on
and on and on right it suffers from
those findings right that that that
document is just very very unwieldly
mechanism for organizing information so
those guys the technical writers came up
with this idea we're going to create a
storyboard and I love this right this is
the if you squint your eyes right and
they develop the standardized slide
format right what's on there like half
of the page is devoted to a graphic and
then a few it starts like hey you're the
thesis support points call them bows
your bullet points and then some more
explanation around this this is squint
your eyes and you see the canonical
slide format there right so there's been
a lot of debate about like you know how
how power perm presentations were
involved in the crash of like spaceships
it's tough T has a long paper on unlike
the tyranny of PowerPoint and in way
like you know we got to stop the hating
of the deck format right it's it's not
the deck that's wrong the tool might be
had particular purpose but the principle
of organizing ideas on a storyboard is
extremely powerful it's one of the few
sense making devices we know and that
that exists so we decided to actually
start in designing a presentation tool
that is optimized around the storyboard
so let me let me just show you what that
looks like
I'm not going to take my chances on this
internet connection so oh no ok so
here's paste I've been actually using
paste and the thing with about we called
it paste is because you can use paste to
quickly paste things ideas in and we
build the slide for you notice we always
start out in the storyboard view here
right so you always move to the higher
level task of organizing your Diaz it's
just keeping focus on on on your flow
it works with modern-day web content so
you take a link you just paste it in and
voila it's there and you have like sort
of the beginning of your idea and your
your your kernel of a thought you
arrange it you just if you have to
provide more context you just tap on on
that artifact you just start writing
this text editor I have the basic
formatting capabilities in it and it can
extend by the way to an entire document
editor as well and then we have like
some higher level formatting tasks if
you want to just highlight something
make it more bold or more neutral and
can very quickly just layout a slide to
like say you know establish a point it
supports richer layouts so here is
actually a preview of our mobile
application you go in we add a couple
more assets and these can be even
rearranged all right stem over the go
it's in somewhat different area all of
this is integrated into slack and and
that's a I'll talk about this actually
let me like actually I'll show you a
little bit more anytime you comment or
have a discussion about this slide it's
actually linked to back into slack into
your communication flow right so you
bring content and conversation together
right and that then allows it to
essentially also distribute work so in
this case if you want to bring in
someone else you can just quickly go in
and make an assignment so here you're
just assigning that - you know KJ and
then that person can come in and help
work help work with you on that
particular slide
and that's sort of the other thing that
happened like while we were designing
mix and and then paper for teams and
then ultimately realizing that you know
there isn't there you know paper isn't
the tool for collaboration we need a
different tool for it a great thing
happening as well around messaging right
and and that is like you know we've been
living in this world of files and
folders for for for eons and like the
idea of a file in a folder really came
from the fact that it was a very
efficient way of storing information but
when you think about it you know 2.8
billion people today like you're using
your phones to like message and text
right and that is how people are now
learning about technology and that
messaging is moving it's moving like
rapidly into the enterprise into teams
and it's it's the first time that we
actually have an organization metaphor
that is centered around people and
that's a huge huge deal right it's if
because it's a it's a metaphor that
people understand if you want to bring
the right set of people around your
content you just create a group or
create a channel and people can then
discuss the work from there I want to
tell you how many more dimensions
messaging is important storage is a
given and messaging you don't even think
about it when Gmail first launched it
advertised a you get like a gigabyte or
whatever our storage that was a big
selling point on and messaging you just
have storage automation is inside of
messaging
they're called BOTS but you know a
message can be moved around and you can
actually program against it and do
different things communication can be
real-time or it can be asynchronous
right so in so many dimensions messaging
is going to fundamentally change how
companies work and what's missing around
that right now is essentially what is
the productivity suite really going to
look like if messaging is the funnel and
fundamental layer of communication right
it won't look like a document centric
model right that goes into files and
folders we're now building for people
groups in communication right so it's
really going to change how this all
works there's a ton of open questions
that come from that the first one is and
this is actually a more of an
organizational design and management
problem
like today most people know how to
manage a hierarchy right they know how
to follow a chain of command like the
military style of president
vice-president you know the chain of
command like my email distribution list
that's how people know how to manage
right but the moment you moved to
messaging you're moving to a world we're
actually
managing lines of communication right
it's a very different way of working and
I don't think like management abilities
are quite yet developed for that there
ton of challenges around visualization
like how can you quickly go from work
artifacts that people are working on to
bubble that up into a visual story you
know some things are very easy to
translate others you know the interface
and the interfacing questions like are
harder right for example like you know
if you just drop a PowerPoint we just
drop it if you have a large data set and
you want to extract the visualization
from that like how what is the UI going
to look like in that process as you're
framing up your story collaborative
workflows like we know what it looks
like when someone works individually on
a document or a deck but the moment you
open that up and append the typical
silos of collaboration and really just
open that all up like well what are
really like the mechanisms for dividing
up work bringing ideas together voting
on things what are all these different
group based like make editing mechanics
on the interface design part like the
phase we're in right now when you look
at messaging it's totally like the
command line era right it's like a lot
of bots in there they feel almost like
text-based
games from the 80s or 90s right so it's
like we're totally in the command line
interface era right now what will the
graphical interface for messaging be
like what are the metaphors what's the
malleus the Pointer the like the icon of
messaging what is that all going to
really be a huge opportunities for a I'm
machine learning obviously like why can
you not just talk to a bot and say is
like hey can you please make sense of
this conversation just visualize it for
us right and just have someone go
through a conversation history and a
chat and build build at least the first
pass at a story questions around
aesthetics like that's a really fun one
like if in the past the presentation was
about persuasion which and you know
that's how you got just lie
transitions animations a lot of slide
theatrics well what should actually the
aesthetics be for a presentation that's
about collaboration that's about making
sense and meaning right there's a it's
it's not obvious to me what that really
should look like because at the same
time we know that when people are
showing their work right they want some
personality to be in it right so it
can't be completely bland but you know
there should be some spark in it oh the
last one is a good one you know are you
interested in these questions we're
hiring at 53 if you want help us solve
any of that stuff
do do do reach out do shout please sorry
short like I'm just gonna leave using
one thought which is like for us like
you know we know technologies are just
going to come and go but the human need
will just never go away and you know
humans are such such noble creatures we
will invent technologies and we every
day have a choice what are we gonna use
this technology for is that you know is
it to sell ads like is it to entertain
is it to distract like we really really
have a choice where we're gonna use
technology and I'm just gonna have one
big ask like somewhere along your career
make sure it serves the human need to
create thank you
[Applause]
yeah so whenever I can't draw they're
gonna I can't draw very well so then
what I do
download paper but it's it's no I mean
it's a really really good question like
people underestimate truly underestimate
their ability this is I'm just gonna
share a story like you know the last
time I was here thing was it was TA in
CS 248 and there is a video game project
I don't know that's still part of that
course and as part of the video game
proposals like we ask people to submit
like a sketch right of what rule that
interface looked like right and I say
40% of the students made apologies for
their sketch and said it's horrible you
know some refused to create the sketch
right but a or 90% of the projects ended
up pretty much building what they
sketched right so yes there were long
descriptions and citations and
references like people oftentimes like
underestimate like how profound a napkin
sketch can be and you just got to do it
then there have tremendous resources
like get paper send us a tweet or
something like they're amazing people
that we can connect you to if you want
to get better but just get started just
really really started yes paste is about
application so you can run that today on
Windows paper so nowhere iPhone and iPad
or only right now that's like we're
still working through the is a whole
nother we're still working through
exactly how to get people to pay for
software and you know we'd like to get
people to pay for software on iphone as
a starter and when we have that figured
out and then we'll take on another
market right but right now that's that's
that's really like I'm just being
completely transparent around that one
like getting people to pay for software
is really tricky
so when you were showing the prototyping
phase of the water with the water color
tool something that occurred to me was
that there's something really beautiful
and intuitive about physically kind of
like letting the brush Lindner and up in
some waters and I I guess I'm realizing
that in the same way that people today
don't necessarily know what to say icon
means like they might not necessarily
understand the intuition behind like
what a paint brush is supposed to
represent and for you I guess are you
seeing that or already thinking about
kind of the shift from where people are
going to stop understanding what that
what the cinetic meaning of these tools
are and yeah I think the the semantic
meaning actually doesn't change right
the save does do a save opera mean in
this case oftentimes it doesn't do
anything it's a web-based part but you
know the the technique to it like might
at some point or the the I would say at
some point the metaphors sort of out
live there use like the familiarizing
metaphors are very helpful at the
beginning for us like watercolor in a
way was a familiarizing metaphor we
didn't create a watercolor tool what we
created is a great tool for coloring all
right so that's kind of like the shift
so like if you want to use watercolor go
get a watercolor set get water and do
all of that stuff and it will produce
really amazing watercolor right but if
you want it quickly for an untrained
hand actually explore the layering of
colors and pigments and how they
interact how we can essentially go from
like and I wanted a little red no I want
more red to like I want this really
really red with like like that type of
expressive it was something we were able
to replicate so it's you wanted like I
think it's one of those things with
biomimicry familiarising metaphor is
like there's a there's a line between
like how much inspiration you take from
it and what actually is the task at hand
and that's super fun to figure out right
because in our case it's kind of like
the coloring effect of watercolor not
and we kind then lost a lot of what like
the insight from water coloring was like
that it blends so well right that's kind
of the thing is how do we give that
control to someone right and then
figuring out that oh wait in a
touch-based interface velocity is
something a human can control right in a
mouse
he is tricky to control right so
joystick tricky to control touch easy to
control right so that's kind of mapping
than those things into the new
environment was sort of the breakthrough
this is business stuff like everybody
thinks that they can't seem something
interesting a problem does your cell
phone do anything to try and like
building a growth lines that are like
maybe you'll feel like overcoming that
psychological barrier yes so the first
is again it builds a beautiful
environment for you to where you want to
actually put your ideas in the second
thing is like the it's again going back
to the power of defaults like the
default tool that we choose in the
product is actually is the draw tool and
the derocker what it does it does
something very unintuitive or at that
time was intuitive since then a lot of
people decided to follow suit it
essentially the faster you go the wider
the line becomes right so in the real
world that never happens if you have a
paintbrush and you move faster you have
less pigment over a larger surface area
the line usually goes smaller right but
a calligrapher is actually trained to do
the inverse like when they want to have
a swooping line they move slowly to put
lots of ink into a corner and then
around and the output is very evocative
graphic so our draw tool actually we
flipped what happens when you move fast
when you go fast it creates flourishes
for you because typically that's when
someone is confident all right you know
we saw it actually some of the queue
here was like what's the first thing
people tried to do is like they write
their name right they don't draw they
actually just write their name and they
would look at what how their name looks
like and that was sort of the first step
in right into the product and then like
you start realizing a lot of tools we
did some of those those things like you
know how colors layer so there are a lot
of details around how we even encourage
people to create more
do you have like any statistics about
your users or like I how do most of the
people using the apps or arts or design
or yeah oh man do we have this stats
yes 57% of their user base uses paper at
work and it reported none and actually
it's only over like 75% of our people
use it in non art setting yeah so it's
it's actually it's a tool that that is
but a lot of people actually use in the
workplace which which you wouldn't tell
by how it looks but again it it's that
is actually what we designed it for is a
really quick idea an ideation tool and
it's you know we just look at you know
we have millions of users right that the
art market just isn't that large right
and it's not that we and in fact we
necessarily we wanted a tool that
actually speaks to a broader audience
right that's there but yeah we have a
lot of stats on our user base so I
haven't both the paper on the pencil and
I think it's a great tool I'm really
curious about why you chose to have a
page with the precise over an infinite
canvas right because it seemed like
you're brainstorming having like an
infinite canvas for you like reading
this book
yeah putting your finger on one of those
really important design decisions right
infinite canvas was a fixed size page
for us it was very important and we in
fact maybe underestimated the importance
of that is giving people a sense of
grounding in the application when you
have an infinite canvas it yes you have
the freedom to move anywhere else right
but the absence of that constraint means
you have to figure out you know how to
organize and orient your work right and
becomes actually fairly disorienting
right and and so having a fixed size
canvas allows people to you know in a
way modernize the work they're doing
allows it to people easier for people to
share the the different ideas that
they're working on and also just orient
people much better in the interface
right you don't have to deal with
creation plus XY panning right at the
same time so that was where we ended up
it's a by the way it's not like one is
better than the other they have their
there right implications but it was just
like in our environment and we were
actually in the next version of paper
you'll see that it will bring back
journals we're making it much more
physical in that sense because it's just
such a big part of experience so I used
paper to describe to my advisor my ideal
results for my dissertation thank you
so I do learning Sciences and so I'm
kind of curious about this problem with
people and drawing and you could imagine
and I've used a lot of tutorials online
that people have done you can do all
these things with inside paper and I'm
wondering do you get the sense that if
people knew more about the tool they
would use it more or is it just getting
in the door and then and that's enough
for most people to be able to
communicate their ideas yeah so I mean
so we worked with different we worked
with the Guggenheim Museum on learning
through art programs Pacific here is
what we found is like you know this
perception that I'm not creative where
people are equating and by the way this
is an us problem like this does not
exist you go to China you go to like you
know Korea like they're like yeah I'll
draw like it's it's it's it's it's a
this is a u.s. problem right equating
drawing with me being creative this is a
very very us thing and it's we don't
know where it starts in the education
process but at some point people are
just have an adverse reaction to it so
we try to address it sometimes like
outside by working with organizations
like you know the learning through art
program big draw like different you know
different different cartoonists Liza
Donnelly like where we just want like
where we try to work with a broader
community then inside the product I
think there is much more we can do right
so we're gonna start adding more
tutorials and just different like EDM
burley I don't know you know and um
release drawing books like they're just
so beautiful that you just want to
give it a try and get people over that
initial hump and I think we have a
really nice environment to do it
I think we haven't done enough about it
but it's something that I'm just like
you know let's it's a good investment of
time and we've got to figure this out
and then you can start thinking about
what are some of the design thinking
toolkits can we add in like better
templates how do we maybe put
prioritization frameworks in there let's
just teach people about diagramming so
you so right now what we've done is
worked with organization like skill
share we have training classes around
this but I think it requires a really a
comprehensive effort like it's not
something like there's a tool but then
you have to understand what's really the
context and when it lives and oftentimes
people that show up like you know
there's probably 10 20 years of
Education that's telling them that and
they're not creative or there shouldn't
be being creative and that's that's hard
to overcome and in a sort of an active
first install right but you know we will
try so but but thanks for the question
and I hope your your-your-your project
turned out as beautiful as you
envisioned it yeah no absolutely
so one it's like we do think like the
combination of paper and paste that
barrier so it didn't get into that but
the is a particular piece that we're
adding to this which is a real-time in
the presence of when you're creating in
paper and someone has an act of paced
session running you can actually share
directly to it so meaning like that idea
of copying pasting right or sending a
link out like we're essentially
attacking this problem by just reducing
the iteration loop right that's kind of
thing we can do like you know people
need to seek out feedback when they want
to and we can we're just going to make
it so easy for you to just go from like
hey dragon drop that idea into paste get
some feedback on it you'll be able to
just essentially instantaneously share
to like an active deck that you're
working on and the hope is by just
reducing the friction between sharing an
idea and putting an environment where
people can comment on it and give
feedback on it will just essentially
increase the level of feedback there is
the process of seeing and listening
right and then also surfacing and that's
kind of where then the storyboard is so
great right where you can then actually
see four opportunities for helping
across an entire organization so the
home view of paste also is another
surfacing point so you know I'll share
that here like if I go to my home view
I'm a little bit I should probably check
that but here you can actually see all
the decks across all the 53 right now so
I can see you know what have people been
working on for the last like while I'm
here giving a talk what happened three
hours ago or four hours ago like this is
another view right we want to fill this
in where you can quickly see all the
work that's happening across an
organization right so it's not just
someone would look working locally and
getting feedback but it's also
peripherally were like you know the
marketing team wants to see what's
happening design the design and
engineering team want to work closer
together really like raising essentially
the awareness of feedback across an
entire organization yeah that's another
view and when a fix or improve like like
a are create something yeah yes I mean
what I would love to see an AR its if I
wanted like take this view here and I
want to like be able to walk into a room
and see like all the ideas of my
colleagues right I mean I work with an
amazing team right and I want to like
just be able to inhabit like that
thought space I want to feel like I'm
working at the best place in the world I
want to be able to just get a sense of
what everyone was working on and be able
to see that right I mean it's kind of
like you know when I look at the
d.school
right now you know they have this design
of mobile whiteboards and all of this
like how cool would it be is like you
just walk into the space and see
everyone's ID
beautifully laid out like I want that
view right so I don't know I mean I
don't know exactly what it would be but
that's kind of like the same experience
yeah it's different like so you know the
usage patterns are different on iPhone
right you see much more photo annotation
working with photos you see text notes
popping up much more on the iPhone there
is some sketching right there's some
sketching that goes on but obviously
like for a larger extent like you know
by the way like the iPad pros are and
I'm not being paid by Apple to say this
but they're really phenomenal like and
and they are very different from
oddly enough they looks the same form
factor wise but like in terms of active
use we're seeing like two to three times
like the session lengths are three times
longer an iPad pro it is qualitatively
it is a different experience right and I
think a lot has to do with them adding a
stylus adding a keyboard adding also now
for the files in the drag-and-drop
metaphors and iOS 11 just makes it a
really different experience right now
and it's actually very positive shift
right because it's pushing that device
clearly into the creation camp not like
the just pure consumption camp so I mean
check it out
meanwhile you know download paper on the
iPhone try it out it's free to try so
give it a shot
all right what with this want to thank
MIDI you for bringing me out here
everyone else for listening and festive
success with your studies
[Applause]
you